[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
will she be okay
you do everything for me you teach me
you'd cook for me am i a burden
sweetheart i could do more i'm your mom
it's my job to take care of you when you
need me
and you need me
are you okay mom of course i'm okay
i have you
[Music]
the medication is messed with her head
what's wrong
[Music]
i really need you to help me chloe good
[Music]
night
you figured it out
you need me
i know how to play the game
[Music]
this game like life requires forethought
so it's not about where you are please i
can't answer all your questions at once
it's where you will be in ten moves or
ten years
a heart attack and how'd that even
happen
dad was in better shape than either of
us
lauren there's something i need to
discuss with you
what is it your father left this for you
and you alone
does any daughter really know her father
show me your face lord
elizabeth monroe
not like him i suspect you're better
than he ever was
who are you i'd like to think i'm a
member of the family
are there any old enemies of dads that i
should be aware of
we both know he was no saint if someone
was threatening our family
and dump his body in the river you said
you could have the truth
i know things i'll take to the grave you
give me what i ask for
and i will tell you everything you think
this is a game
what else was my dad hiding a lawyer
a banker a politician who'd you talk to
an unholy trinity your father had no
right to do what he did
quite the family it doesn't prove
anything
it doesn't prove anything when all is
said and done
you will know the truth
and you will set me free
the truth must stay buried
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on
it's okay baby it's okay mom yeah
it's okay it's okay we're okay we're
okay
okay where where where
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
run
i don't know why he came all the way up
here there's nothing left
please there are people out there
the people that are left
are not the kind of people worth saving
sweet home i'm guessing you're not from
these parts
we just moved down from new york
[Music]
no peeking let's give it another try
there's no reason we can't have children
we already tried
twice both babies died holy mary
mother of god
nobody told you the previous owners they
got killed in this house
[Music]
house of blood god i need another bottle
honey a real van gogh yeah sure where
did you get all this stuff
the room makes things what do you need
most in the world i want a million
dollars
how does it work who cares how it works
you just
use it the only thing more dangerous
than a person that can't get what they
want is a person who gets whatever they
want
get out of the house before it's too
late where's the necklace you asked for
i can always get another
and another and
another what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
i took a shortcut you used the room to
make a baby
baby it's not a thing yes it is
you never take that stuff outdoors
i'm not doing this feel free to leave
anytime you want i wanna be with you
forever
are you afraid of him of course i am
you're not a real person
man wants to be free but first the
creator must die
you said you'd be together forever mr
roo go with me
mommy daddy
[Music]
many homes have the pretence of being
ideal
but these homes really are ideal
it's not exactly what we're looking for
wait no no i don't think this is the
right way yeah this is where we came in
no is it did we just do some kind of
loot
hello
i've never had such silence
what if they don't come
what are we supposed to do
this house is forever a perfect
environment for a young family
people like to be alone sometimes not be
with each other
all the time
this is something i can do please just
let me do this it's acting like eric's
mother
i want to go
that's nature that's just the way things
are
[Music]
henry
there's something i think you need to
take a look at
what might that be a girl was taken to
st
john's she lost her family
it's not unusual
it's the circumstance
i think you need to take a look at this
[Music]
she only knows what the demon allows her
to see
the blood of christ
[Applause]
something's wrong
and then this figure appears
he's going to rescue me he pushes me up
towards the surface
and then you wake up
your name is rudy watts you're 25 years
old you remain captive until you fall in
love with me
i'll bring you food three times a day
help you wash
every other day if you need to go to the
toilet
i will help you do not try to escape
we're miles from the nearest household
and your legs don't work
what happens if i don't fall in love
with you
will i stay here for the rest of my life
i know you're only trying to help me
can we have a candle it would be
romantic
i wouldn't want you to have done this
for someone else
this is special we're making progress
aren't we
don't trust
him how many others come
what how many others have you kidnapped
before me
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
that was the first time i saw her but
before we talk about her i have to tell
you something about me
when i was nine we moved to micah
arizona
as the new kid i became the center of
attention real fast
and not in a good way it was then that i
realized i was gonna need to disappear
no one would see me no one would hear me
i was gonna have to be just like
everybody else
and then one day when some loud
bragger tries to put me down what's her
name anyway
star girl my name is star girl
so be true to your school you should
talk to her
she likes you she doesn't
[Music]
i don't really know her but maybe if you
did you might
won't you let me walk you home
from school mom were you ever afraid of
what people thought of you
figuring out who we are is the one thing
no one else can do for us
won't you let me meet you at the pool
did you want to ask me something if it's
so
well let me know sometimes i'm quiet but
i'm just thinking scream leo why would i
do that
don't you want the universe to hear you
since she got here things have been
different
some people are just like that being
with you is the most anyone has ever
looked at me in my entire life
there's just something about her she's
not like anyone else
is she magic
[Music]
you think things have to be real more
magic
but the best things
[Music]
are both
[Music]
natasha my sister after all this time
what brings you home
[Applause]
i'm on the run
i was trying to do something good
[Music]
you're more than just a trained killer
you're fooling yourself
[Music]
we are still both train killers
[Music]
we have unfinished business
family back together again you got
fat smelly water
there's a new world of widows
new enemies
i'm done running for my past
who the hell is that guy
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
wanda welcome home
vision residents
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna burn this place to the ground
[Music]
what do you do when someone says
something's impossible
i prove it's possible
[Music]
not everything in life makes sense
[Music]
one day many years from now
you'll wonder if this really happened
[Music]
or if it was a dream
everyone is connected to the loop
in one way or another
[Music]
see there's nothing to be afraid of
you